[MUSIC PLAYING]
KONSTANTINE TSOTSOS:
Thank you all for coming.
My name's Konstantine Tsotsos.
I'm a software engineer
here at Google.
Today we're going to talk about
realism for augmented reality,
and how you can
use some new things
we're bringing to
Lighting in ARCore
to make your ARCore apps a lot
more immersive, and believable,
and realistic.
The way we're going
to do that is we're
going to give you a
high-level overview of why
we care about realism, what
tells us about immersion
in augmented reality.
Then go through a whole ton
of technical details of how
we do it, give you
the nitty-gritty,
and then walk through some
live demos and wrap it up.
Let's get started.
Augmented reality
has always promised
to blend the virtual
with the real.
What we really want is
for our virtual character
to actually look like
it's in our living room,
to look like it's interacting
with the environment,
to look like it's actually
in broad daylight sunshine.
And for all of that to
blend with the environment
in a natural, seamless way.
And for all of you,
you'd like to be
able to implement that easily
without that much work,
hopefully.
And the way that
all of this happens
is by taking advantage of cues
that we see in the environment
and making sure that
the way that we present
our virtual characters in
an augmented reality app
fits that environment.
So let's take a look at
a fairly standard scene
and walk through
what's going on here.
So here we've got a couple
of chairs, a table, a floor,
some walls.
We look at this scene
as humans and we see,
oh, it's a bunch of
objects and surfaces
and there's light coming
in, and we naturally
understand what's
going on in the scene,
where the light's coming from.
We see directions of shadows.
Turns out that when we
render stuff in our computers
and on our phones for
a virtual character
we use a fairly similar process.
We have a bunch of assets.
Those assets are represented
by geometry that has surfaces.
Those surfaces have
material properties.
Maybe it's rough and diffuse
or it's specular, really shiny,
metallic.
We put in a light into
our virtual scene,
and then that light bounces
off of those surfaces
when we render our image and
goes into the camera view.
And that's how we
generate the images
that we see in our computers.
The difference here is sort
of similar to the way in CGI
we generate
computer-generated imagery
to show special effects.
If you have really
great CGI, that
looks fantastic and
believable, and if you
have not so great
CGI, it pulls you out
of the moment like that.
It immediately breaks
your immersion.
Let's look a little bit at
how that happens or why.
Some of the first
cues that we look
at when we see these
images are things
called specular highlights.
These are really shiny
bits of surfaces,
like the edge of the
chair there or the edge
of the table where--
because of the nature of the
material and the geometry
we see a highlight
from an incoming light.
As we move around the scene,
and as we're viewing it,
that highlight tends
to move with us,
because that's the way
these kinds of highlights
behave in a scene.
The next thing we pick up on
is the shadows of the scene.
Here we see a couple different
directions of shadows
because we have some
overhead light coming
in from a bit towards the
upper right of the image,
and it's casting shadows
on the chair and the table.
That tells us something about
how is this scene laid out
and where the light's
coming from in that scene.
If those shadows are
wrong, it immediately
doesn't fit our
impression of the scene.
Shading is another
important bit,
where depending on the kind of
light and the kind of surfaces,
you see intensity of
light coming back at you
change as you move
along that surface.
Think of looking at a very
dull ball, or maybe this chair
you're seeing up on
the stage right here.
As the light plays
across it you see
changing amounts of
light coming back at you
based off of the angle of the
surface relative to that light.
Finally, reflection is another
big cue that we look at where--
here we've got a couple
of really shiny things
like the table that's reflecting
a whole bunch of the wall.
And we have a whole bunch
of wood tones on the floor
and on the chairs.
As light comes in, bounces
off of these surfaces
and then comes to
our eyes, it picks up
a bunch of the light and
intensity from those surfaces,
and so you end up having
some reflected colors.
If you put an object
in a blue room,
it's going to look
a little blue.
That's the same thing
that happens here,
and that's a big import--
that's an important part of CGI
as well.
All of these cues
together tell us
that this is a
real, natural scene.
And unfortunately,
humans are actually
really good at perception.
We're wildly good at it.
It makes our jobs as computer
vision engineers really,
really difficult. We
look at this scene
and can immediately detect
when something doesn't fit,
when something is unrealistic.
And we're great at spotting
fakes and mistakes.
So let's see what
this looks like
if we want to put an
actual object in here.
Here's a really, really
shiny specular rocket.
It's brand new.
It's got lots of fine
details in the rivets,
it's got a shiny window,
some complicated geometry.
And we're going to try and
light this in our scene
using a bunch of
fairly naive methods
that you might be able to do
out of the box with smartphone
AR today.
And this is a very
challenging case for this
because it's a really
specular, shiny rocket.
So we stuck our rocket
in there and we're
using a few basic things.
We got a guess of the
overhead lighting,
so we have a directional
light coming straight down.
Shadow doesn't quite match.
It's not going in
the right direction.
We're using a
coarse ambient term
that represents the
average pixel intensity
of the entire scene.
Doesn't look quite like it fits.
Looks pretty virtual to me.
What we'd love is for the
rocket that we put in,
this nice shiny rocket,
to look a bit more
like what you're seeing on the
right of the screen over there.
Here we're seeing that
that rocket actually
blends much more nicely with
the scene that we're looking at.
We've got a
directional shadow that
matches the shadows around it.
We've got specular
highlights that
cover large chunks of the rocket
representing where the light is
actually coming from.
Along the sides
you see that some
of the shading of the
rocket is picking up
the colors of the
ambient environment.
This looks a lot more
believable to me,
and this looks like an ideal
case for lighting this rocket.
Well, luckily this
was captured live
on a Pixel 3 using
environmental HDR, which
is a new mode for
lighting estimation
that we're bringing to ARCore.
And this will be available
in ARCore later this summer.
Let's peel back
some of the layers
of what these APIs
are actually doing
and how they build up to this
well-lit, believable, immersive
rocket you're seeing here.
The first thing that we're
going to be giving you
is a main directional
light out of this API.
Here we're lighting
the rocket using
just this directional light.
A big thing that
you can pick up here
is that we now have
a directional shadow
on the back end of that rocket
that matches the environment,
and we're getting some of
the specular highlights,
because now we actually have
a realistic light coming
from a particular point of
view, that's not straight down.
The next piece are ambient
spherical harmonics.
Now, this is a very common
and useful representation
of lighting that gives you a
sense of the overall intensity
of light coming in from
all around the environment.
And once we've
added this in, you
can see a bit more shading is
coming in on the bottom end
of the rocket.
Not all of it yet, though,
because this is really, really
shiny.
And we're still
missing a piece here.
The final pieces are high
dynamic range cube map.
This is what's
going to bring you
to this full ideal
version of the rocket.
Once we bring that in
you get full specular
highlights and reflections.
There's another really
common representation
you can plug into
your graphics engine
to handle specular objects.
You see shading along
the bottom of the rocket.
And you see a whole
ton of reflected color
now coming in from
the environment.
The sides of the
rocket are actually
picking up those wood tones.
Let's see what this looks
like in a few other natural
environments.
Here we took our
beautiful little rocket
and played with it
around the Bay Area.
It's watching the sunset,
playing in the park,
watching the boats by the water,
parking its car in a garage,
I guess.
And in all of
these cases, you're
seeing that the shading is
matching the environment,
the specular highlights
match what's believable,
and the shadows match
what's actually coming
in-- mostly here from sunlight.
Some more examples for you.
Our rocket's out to grab
some dinner, hanging out
in an office, out on a
patio watching some tourist
sites near the Bay
Bridge, then indoors
again with lots of
strong light coming
in from the outdoor world.
Last highlights reel, I promise.
Here we're seeing our rocket
in another office setting,
in another indoor setting with
some strong bright lighting,
a few other cases with lots
of external lighting coming in
around, and another
scene in a park.
So that's what it looks
like out in the wild.
But what about for you
to play with today?
Here's a new scene where--
I want to do a little
bit of a poll--
one of these
mannequins is virtual.
If you think the virtual one is
on the left, raise your hand.
on the right, raise your hand.
If you saw this gag yesterday
in "What's New in ARCore,"
raise your hand.
Great.
Lots of repeat viewers.
So the mannequin on the left
is the virtual one here.
We're lighting it using
environmental HDR.
You can see as the directional
light pans across the scene
that the shading
on that mannequin
is changing to match the
real one right next to it.
And this is actually a
snapshot from our sandbox demo
that you can play with
across the way over there.
The next place-- and here
you can see environmental HDR
being toggled on and off.
Here you see a lot more
of the color tone impact
that I was talking about
in the previous scene.
As we switch it off right
there, doesn't really match.
Once it's on, we have a lot
of the same golden tones
that are visible on
the real mannequin.
The next place
you're going to be
able to see environmental HDR is
in Scene Viewer, which we also
talked about yesterday in the
"What's New in ARCore" session.
This is a new way to
view your 3D models live
in the space in front of you.
And we're thrilled to announce
that environmental HDR will
be coming to Scene Viewer later
this summer in an upcoming
release.
So you'll be able to have
this Curiosity Rover,
plop it into your living
room, and have it actually
look realistic and immersive
in your living room.
Though if it looks real
in your living room,
you might have to match
your furniture to it,
that might be a bit hard.
So now I'd love to
hand this over to Alex
to give us a deep dive into
how environmental HDR actually
works.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
ALEX MA: Thank you, Konstantine.
Hi everyone.
My name's Alex Ma.
I'm a software engineer
at Google Daydream.
I'm really happy to
be here to give you
a deep dive into the technology
behind this new feature.
So let's take a look at this.
Beautiful picture, isn't it?
This is the image actually--
a computer graphics
rendering for a short film.
Rendering with natural light
produced by Dr. [INAUDIBLE]
and his team in 1998.
All the spheres, the holders,
and the table are 3D models.
They're not real.
So only the background,
as you can see,
full screen, are actually--
that environment
light itself was
captured from the real world.
So you can see from
the scene, light
are scattered through the
treetops and getting refracted
or refracted onto different
surfaces on this thing.
This is a very good example of
how environmental lighting can
contribute to the realism
of virtual object,
even though the
geometry is very simple.
So in real world, light
comes from everywhere.
The appearance of an
object is influenced
by the light running from
all incidental directions
around it.
Some directions may have a
stronger influence while some
don't.
But they all contribute to
the object appearance one
way or another.
Without environmental lighting,
as you can see on the screen,
this is a very
simple set-up with
a typical directional light.
And what does it look like?
This looks very boring.
And this is actually typically
what we do during AR lighting
today, because we don't
have any knowledge of how
the lighting came from and
what is the whole environment
lighting is.
How about this one?
So, you see?
With the same set-up but
with environmental lighting,
it significantly increased
the realism of virtual object.
Then the question becomes,
how do we actually
capture this
environmental lighting?
So Dr. [INAUDIBLE]
established a modern framework
of High Dynamic Range Imaging,
or HDRI, as we [INAUDIBLE]
in computer graphics
and visual effects.
To acquire
environmental lighting,
a typical setup is to use a
camera with a telephoto lens
to shoot a mirror sphere.
Shoot even one
direction, it generally
covers almost the entire
specific environment.
But the usual practice
is, we'll shoot the mirror
ball from opposite directions.
And in this way we can
reduce image distortion.
And also it's easier to
remove the tripod, the camera,
and the photographer
for that image.
We also want to capture
the lighting environment
with multiple exposures.
It's something to do with
what we call dynamic range.
We will cover it later.
But you can see from here
because the sky is real bright,
such like if you want to
capture the detail from the sky
or a treetop, we have to use a
shorter exposure while-- if you
want to cover the
detail on the ground,
then we need [INAUDIBLE] it will
become longer because usually
people-- things
on the ground will
be much darker in this case.
We then fuse all the
photographs into this image
to what we call a light prop.
This is essentially
the very [INAUDIBLE]
for a remnant of lighting.
And this is the most
common way to do lighting
in visual effects right now.
As you can see, how they
render photo-realistic
CGI creates an element
in blockbuster movies.
So there are two
interesting facts here.
The first one-- so this
is an image with about 900
by 900 pixels.
Every piece on
here is effectively
a light source, no matter how
bright or how big they are.
So in this case, there are more
than 600,000 lights already,
just with this texture.
And secondly, you can
see a very interesting
coming back the lighting range.
The range is about
5,000 to 1, which
means the brightest
pixel here is
5,000 times brighter
than the darkest pixel.
Usually your phone, the
camera on your phone,
basically have 8-bit of range,
which means the range is only
from 255 to 1.
How can you get that fancy one?
It's a very challenging case.
That's why we had to actually--
in shooting this type of way
to change that is for
your time such as it
will cover the
whole dynamic range.
But this is also
impossible for AR.
So now we all know
environmental lighting is great.
So how can we actually
bring this technique to AR?
So let's take a look at what
are the challenges here.
As we said still earlier,
the first challenge
is dynamic range.
So, for example, by looking
at this picture here--
and we have different
multiple exposures
showing on the screen--
you can suddenly see, for
example, the reading on a chair
at the bottom of the image.
It's pretty fit to the
8-bit range of your camera.
However, for the top, no matter
how you change the exposure
setting, it always give
you 255 because that
is facing a very bright area.
The outdoor sunlight basically
casts through the window
and get into the
indoor environment.
So no matter how you
change exposure setting,
you never get the right
answer for the lighting.
Lighting there is
simply just clipped.
Then, without knowing
that information,
you can never render
a very good image
based on this piece of lighting.
A similar dynamic range should
happen with artificial light
that we see in
this indoor scene.
As you can see, no matter how
we change the exposure time,
the light sources on
top are always clipped.
And it's also very hard
to find a good range
of exposures setting that you
can cover the entire image.
So remember how we--
remember how we were
talking about how
to capture the light mirror
ball with multiple exposure?
This is exactly trying
to solve the same issue.
But in AR we cannot
do this in real time.
The consequence of not
having enough dynamic range
is that your lighting
environment does not
have the correct
energy for computation.
The light source
are usually clipped.
So the rendering looks dull,
as you can see on the left.
But having a light
energy with HDR--
then you certainly see
the rendering on the right
is more accurate
because, in this case,
the environment is actually
a [INAUDIBLE] thing
with a very strong sunlight and
you can see, actually see space
for spectral refreshing on
top of the rocket surface.
So here we show
another indoor scene--
it's our parking garage.
So even with this slightly
lower dynamic range--
in this case this is indoor--
as you can see on the
[? topic ?] window
the refraction is
still very faithful
if you render with HDR.
It looked more contract and
more physically correct.
The second challenge comes from
how our camera sees the world.
For AR, we visualize
everything with our camera.
A typical mobile phone
camera only cover about 6%
of the 360 environment.
That's a tiny fraction
of the whole thing we
are seeing in this environment.
And as a usual
practice, usually we
are pointing our
phone to the ground
or to a table tower when
we're engaging a AR typical
wanted dropped object onto it.
Or we are pointing to the
person, where maybe you
will do a AR selfie.
It's never going to pointing
your camera to the light source
directly unless they're-- oh,
where are the light source
in this thing?
This is almost
impossible to do when
we're engaged in an AR session.
So how to fill this missing
information becomes-- also
becomes a challenge.
In the previous
case, we are dealing
with this problem
with a mirror ball,
because a mirror ball,
where we see the reflection,
you have to cover the
whole 360 environment.
But in this case,
we don't want a user
to actually-- when they start to
use AR application-- they start
to put a mirror ball
in front of their phone
and try to look around.
And that's a very tedious job.
So how can we actually provide
360 environmental lighting
for AR with such a limited
field of input and also LDR?
So we still like the
idea to put a mirror ball
in front of the phone.
We don't want our user
to do it, so we actually
do it by ourselves.
So here you can see
this would actually
be the rig that was not
only the mirror ball sphere
here, but we also add a diffuse
and the [INAUDIBLE] sphere.
I will talk you more about why
we are adding more spheres here
later, but we actually designed
this rig such that this--
the image for the sphere
are actually the lighting
measurement [INAUDIBLE].
I would put a
mobile camera here,
as you can see, to actually
look at the three spheres
here while looking at the
image that the camera can see.
But typically the image
will look like this.
And you can see the
pattern you see all sphere
images that actually come from
the HDL lighting measurement.
So actually we try to use
the three sphere to measure
lighting [INAUDIBLE].
Remember we talk about before?
We simply use a simple single
mirror ball to shoot HDI.
However, it isn't, because we
cannot trick the exposure time
for a phone.
We actually have
to add a diffuse
and measure to
actually simulate we
are changing exposure setting.
So as you can see on the screen,
the mirror ball refraction
usually clip as we say
before, because we only
have 8-bit range
for the camera here.
But the diffuse
refraction from the middle
is actually suitable
for us to capture
the entire amount of the energy
for the lighting arrangement.
Because usually it
worked very well
with other exposure
setting for the camera,
and usually the
diffuse refactoring
will not be saturated at all.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
of AR record lighting
for viewing just in between
the diffuse and spectral light
give us more information
that we can interpolate.
In our world, we
add more measurement
prop instead of tweaking the
exposure time from the phone.
So this work basically
establish the mapping
between the input and output.
So the input will
be the rear camera
image and output will be our
lighting measurements that
will be output for the user.
So the rig is very light
and give us the freedom
to walk around and
take more measurements
in different environments
to help us understand more
about mapping between
the input and output.
As you can see, the
mapping between these two
can be very complex.
So we try to leverage the
law of large number and use
machine learning too.
If we can collect more of these
kind of samples, then maybe
we can [INAUDIBLE] very good.
So far we have about 50 million
of these kind of samples,
and the number
are still growing.
So use all the sample we
have, we start a trend.
A new network that
can try to establish
the mapping between
the input/output
and start to generate HDI
light [INAUDIBLE] just
simply based on the
camera imaging feed
from a mobile device.
The research is
done already and we
are happy that the
paper is accepted
by a very important [INAUDIBLE]
conference, committee
region, and patent
recognition this year.
And in summer we are going
to present work there.
And this paper is
already on archive
so you can pretty
easily Google the title
and that give you the PDF.
You can have a preview of it.
Now we have a
basic understanding
about how we can actually put
use HDR lighting for simply
a camera image.
Now let's see what we can
offer to the developer
to let it-- to use this
very good asset for them
to render realistic objects.
First, we will offer the major--
main-- directional light.
Like basically come from the
most important contribution
for the lighting
environment itself.
In this case, we're offering
direction and intensity
for this typical
lighting representation.
And you can also use the
direction to cast shadows.
Usually shadow technique,
like shadow mapping
or even percentage
closer filtering,
they rely on a
single direction that
allows you to employ your shadow
camera to look at the object.
So light direction will be
very helpful to do this job.
The second we're researching
is about [INAUDIBLE] emulation.
So we do not simply want to just
provide a typical offset base
ambient to the developers.
So we want to make
sure everything
can be physically correct.
So in this case, we're going
to model our MPN immersion
as 27 spherical
harmonics coefficient.
So spherical harmonics
is very popular
lighting representation
for having use
in video game or visual
effects for many years.
So it serves a very good
approximation of [INAUDIBLE]
and typically works very
well with natural lighting
environment.
So in this case, we're going
to remove the directional light
component because we
don't want to duplicate
lighting contribution here.
In that way, we can find the
actual ambient contribution.
Then we can begin to compute
the coefficient of each sphere
harmonics basis function.
So sphere harmonics
is very similar
to free or transform
or DCT transform,
but it's actually
defined on a sphere.
So it's basically a series
of basic functioning.
If you edit them
out one by one, you
start to approximate
your function
much, much more accurate.
It's starting with
a constant, then
typically you are
using more coefficient
to actually model the actual
energy for your lighting
environment.
In typical case,
people use label two,
which have night
coefficient [INAUDIBLE]
and that give you
27 coefficient.
And this is very popular
in graphics engine
like Unity or Unreal.
They mostly support
sphere harmonics.
So you can simply grab the
number and just plug it in.
That will do the job.
If you are interested in knowing
more about sphere harmonics,
Google the keywords for
[INAUDIBLE] lighting.
That'll probably give you the--
this paper by Robyn
Green that has
a very detailed
introduction on how
to use spherical
harmonics for lighting.
Last and most importantly,
we will offer full HDR.
16-bit floating point precision
cubemap for the developers.
It is essentially the native
representation for this HDR
lighting environment.
So instead we give
you the prop--
will actually give
you a much more useful
representing because
cubemap is a-- people
use cubemap everyday.
So it's very useful
if you want to create
a shiny or classic refreshing
look for your object,
or even you can just grab
the simple native information
and try to use any of
those rendering technique
you can find in visual effects.
So we also try to introduce
new-- two new concept
for AR lighting.
First, the lighting output that
we are giving to the developer,
essentially what we
call relative intensity.
That means-- because usually
when you is using AR,
your camera is already
in auto exposure mode.
So when you look at
different thing--
it's for your time changing
why you are doing--
engaging with AR.
As you can see on the screen,
if I'm looking at the ground
because the ground
reflects less light,
so the camera
actually automatically
expand exposure time trying to
make an image look adequate.
And while I'm looking
at a window, which
is much stronger,
brighter than the ground,
they start to shorten
that exposure time.
So we don't want the
developer to actually worry
about how to handle
exposure time, or ISO value,
or even color correction,
white balance.
We simply try to aggregate every
information to the output such
that when you grab the
lighting value from our API,
it's already
consider all of that,
and you simply just
grab it and plug it
into your graphic engine.
[INAUDIBLE] basically
just give you
the right look for your object.
There also-- we are shifting
into a more physically correct
framework.
We're going to provide you
with linear lighting process
where it's very
common in visual field
that when you do lighting
everything it will be linear.
So in this case,
for example, you
can start to use your 3D Max or
Maya package to prepare your 3D
asset.
Then all the numbers can
be easily brought to--
into our AR kind of environment.
So to this stage we're
happy to introduce
to you three different
APIs and their properties.
Let's take a look at
how you can use them
to your shading framework.
So typically, the
mentor should not
give you the major look
of your virtual object.
And sometimes you can even use
a direction to cast a shadow.
So ambient we're taking
care of all the rest--
I'm all over the
environment energy
and it casts onto the object.
And finally, you
can use HDR cubemap
to create a realistic look for
the refraction, the glassiness
of the object.
And by using this
all three, it really
depends on your creativity.
Try to define what is
a look for your object.
Entirely up to you to
weigh different things
and try to find the best
material you can represent
for your virtual object.
The tools are there,
please use it.
For myself, I've been
working in visual effects
industry for several years
before joining Google.
And I always had the
dream that if someday we
can share this
super cool lighting
technology that we learn from
there to the general public.
So that with a single mobile
device is actually make you
like a director,
or cinematographer,
or even you can shoot your
own movie-- video-type movie--
with this stuff as an option.
So AI is simply blending
virtual with real.
And that's exactly what
Visual Effects does.
So today we are happy to
actually announce this API
and hope you can use it.
Let's take a look
what the actual code--
how can we introduce the
features in our code.
So let's take a look Java APIs.
So this is a typical setting
for the directional API.
So it's very similar
to what we had before,
but now we are introducing a new
mode called environmental HDR.
So you state a mode, and
you're getting a light estimate
for every frame.
And from there you can
try to use a function
getMainLightDirection
or getMainLightIntensity
to get the direction
and light intended
for that directional light.
Similar things happen with
ambient sphere harmonics.
So you would just need to use
get ambient sphere harmonics,
then that would give you
the sphere harmonic value
that you plug into
your graphics engine.
And finally will
be the HDR cubemap.
Then it will give you an
array of six android image.
Then you use that-- you
upload those to the GPU
and starting from there.
And for Unity, it
will be much easier.
Basically for the
ARCore config you simply
set the environment HDR mode.
Then you'll be automatic--
I'll try-- we'll try to update--
all the properties
in Unity underneath.
Thank you.
This concludes the deep
dive part of this HDR
environmental lighting.
I would like to actually
thank the people who
work behind this technology
because they can't be here
today.
Let's give them a
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
Because then I can
be here to present
this cool feature for you.
Thank you.
Let's give the stage
back to Konstantine.
He will do a live demo.
Thank you.
KONSTANTINE TSOTSOS:
Thank you, Alex.
All right.
Are we ready to
play with it live?
Could I get the lights over
towards one side, please?
All right.
So I'm going to start
up by firing up the app.
This is going to be the
same app in the same model
that you've been seeing in all
of our examples so far today.
So hopefully things
should look familiar.
Here's our rocket
that we've gotten
used to seeing with all of
the environmental HDR running.
If you take a look, you can see
that the shadows are actually
matching what we're
seeing on the environment.
Let's dwell here for a second.
You can see we've got a shadow
matching the line coming off
of the rest of the
objects we've got here.
If I take a closer look, you can
see these specular highlights
are actually following
me around as I'm
looking around the object.
That's what we expect.
That's the way
lighting naturally
behaves when you're
looking at something
really shiny and reflective.
Let's start pulling back
some of these layers
so you can see the backwards
walk through the APIs
that we presented.
First, let's turn off the
high dynamic range cubemap.
Now we still have
the shadow here,
you can see we've lost a lot of
the reflective characteristics
of the entire model.
We still have a little bit
of the specular highlight
and the reflections,
but that's just
coming from the single
directional light.
Let's take off the ambient
spherical harmonics now.
Let me toggle that
a little bit for you
just so you can see
the impact there.
We're losing a whole bunch of
the overall ambient shading
and overall ambient
intensity of the scene
when we turn that
off, but we still
have the directional
light on there.
Let's turn that off now.
Whoops.
Now there's no light in the
scene and we can't do too much.
But if we toggle
that back on and off,
you can see that
directional shadow coming in
and those specular highlights
coming back up right
on the tip of the rocket there.
Let's go back to smartphone
AR before environmental HDR.
And here's our sort
of naively lit model
where we have a single
directional light.
The shadows don't really match.
The overall characteristic of
the scene isn't represented.
And everything isn't nice
and shiny and reflective.
Let's try a slightly
different demo now.
We're going to fire
up another app.
And you may see something
familiar in this one
that you've been seeing in
a bunch of the slides Alex
was presenting.
Up in the top right there
you've got the light probe
for this environment.
This is the light
probe that we're
estimating from
environmental HDR,
that we're packaging
into an API.
Here are a few really
shiny androids.
Let's zoom in on
these guys a little.
The directional shadows are
matching the environment,
as we expect.
Could we move the lights
over, please?, Thank you.
Now we see those
shadows drifting
to match the new environmental
characteristics that we have,
where the shadows are now coming
from a completely different
direction.
If we zoom in a
little again, we can
see as exposure changes
those androids still
look pretty realistic.
Could we change the
lights back again, please?
Now those shadows
are moving back
towards the other direction,
the way they were originally.
That's it for the live demo.
[APPLAUSE]
It's pretty cool, eh?
It's actually really cool.
So what did we talk about today?
Today we presented
environmental HDR to you,
ran through a whole
ton of the details.
And this is a new mode coming
to the lighting estimation
API for ARCore.
it's going to be
coming this summer,
but that doesn't mean you
can't start building today.
You can go download ARCore,
start building your app,
and once environmental
HDR becomes available,
just plug it in.
These are all really easy to
use with any typical graphics
library.
What it's going to be giving
you is a main directional light,
ambient spherical harmonics, and
a high dynamic range cubemap.
Where else can you
see this today?
Well, go play with our sandbox
demo just across the road.
We hope you've enjoyed our talk.
Thank you so much
and have a great IO.
[MUSIC PLAYING]